zoraster was the founder of Zoran ISM
also known as
parismad and the
aesta aista is also called as zista the
Das is further divided into
and the AA is also further divided intoa
and kala also known as Zen and
mahend if you read these par scriptures
in several places Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Al wasallam has been
prophesized it's mentioned in the aesta
in Far Yash chapter number 28 verse
number 129 it says that his name will be
victorious his name will be a
ARA he will be called asan it says that
he will be called as Victorious as
soent his name will be a and we know
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
was
victorious in fat
makah and the word soan according to
Hastings Encyclopedia means a person who
is
praiseworthy which is the translation of
the Arabic word Muhammad s wasallam so
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
mentioned by name in the par scriptures
It also says he will be
a means a person who praises which is
the translation of the second name of
MMI wasallam that is Ahmed Ahmed also
means one who praises further it's
prophesized in the aesta in
Z Chapter number 16 verse number 95 that
his
friends will come the friends of
AA who will be fighting against the
evil they will be well thinking well
speaking and well
doing and their tongue will not utter a
single
falsehood this is talking about the
sahaba and the name again is
mentioned which means one who praises
that is
Ahmed peace be upon him which is the
other name of M wasallam it talks about
the sahabas that the companions of the
Prophet will be good people they'll be
well thinking speaking good things
they'll be doing good things and their
tongue will never utter a falsehood that
means they will not tell a single lie
and we know from history that all the
sahabas mashallah they were
truthful Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is also prophesized in
the Dasa that is the other scripture of
the pares
the means D and means a book containing
10 parts it is also plural of d d means
a religious law so it is a book
containing 10 parts a religious law it's
mentioned in the when the pares will
forsake the religion when the Zoras will
forsake the religion and they will
become
desolate a man will arise from the
desert his followers will subjugate the
Persians and Will Conquer The Arrogant
Persians they will be a mercy to the
humankind they will not worship the fire
in the temple but will pray in the
direction of the house of God of Abraham
which will be free from
Idols they will be the Masters and
rulers of Persia thus
and the other religious places of Persia
of the pares and their Prophet will be a
eloquent person doing miraculous things
this prophecy also refers to No One But
the last and final messenger Prophet
muhmmad Salli wasallam it further
mentioned in the Bund has chapter number
30: 6 to 27 that the soan shall be the
last prophet so as I mentioned earlier
according to the history encyclopedia
means
one who is praiseworthy referring to
Muhammad Sall wasallam and it says in
the prophecy Muhammad sallu alaihi
wasallam will be the last
prophet this was in brief regarding
mhammad sallallah Al wasallam in the
Pary scriptures let's discuss the
prophecy of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him in the Buddhist
scriptures almost all the Buddhist
scriptures they speak about a Mitri to
come it's also mentioned in cha t d
11176 it says that another Buddha will
come by the name of
MRI the Holy One the Supreme one the
enlightened one endowed with wisdom and
conduct auspicious having knowledge of
the
universe whatever he will get from
Supernatural knowledge he will preach to
the whole world he will preach a
religion which would be glorious at the
beginning
glorious at the climax and glorious at
the end he will preach a way of life
with will be truthful and wholly perfect
he will have several thousands of mons
as I have several hundreds of
mons this prophecy is also repeated in
the sacred books of the East volume 35
page number 225 that a Mitri will come
which such and such criteria and and
qualities and further it says that he
will be a leader of thousands of people
as I'm a leader of hundreds of people it
further mentioned in the gospel of
Buddha page number 217 and 18 that
Ananda he asks
Buddha that oh blessed one after you
have gone who will guide us so the
blessed one Buddha he replied that I am
not the first Buddha in this world
neither am I the last there will be
another Buddha who will come the Holy
One the Supreme one the enlightened one
endured with wisdom and conduct the
auspicious having knowledge of the
universe he will preach a good religion
he will preach a religion which would be
glorious at the beginning glorious at
the climax and glorious at the
end he will teach a religion which will
based on truth and will be a perfect way
of life
life and he will have many thousands of
disciples as I have only hundreds of
disciples theand asks Buddha the blessed
one how will we know him so budha
replies he will be called as
Mitri Mitri means the merciful loving
kind compassionate one equivalent Arabic
word is R and Allah says in the Quran
inia chapter number 21 verse number
107 we have sent thee not but as a mercy
to all the world as a mercy to all the
creatures as a mercy to the whole of
humanity this word rahma mercy and its
derivatives are mentioned in the Quran
no less than 409 times and every chapter
of the Quran except for Surah to chapter
number n begins with the beautiful
formula in the name of Allah most
gracious most
merciful so the Buddhist scriptures
almost all of them prophesies about the
might three that is Muhammad sallah Al
wasallam to come Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is further prophesized
in the Buddhist scriptures which is
mentioned in the sacred books of the
East volume number 11 page number
Mah chapter number
two verse number 32
it says
that as for the Buddha there are no
exoteric or esoteric teachers and Alanda
the tatas that mean the teachers have
nothing like a closed fist we cannot
keep the knowledge to ourselves it
should be proclaimed and we know mamad
sah Ali wasallam whatever he received as
a from Allah subhana wa taala he
proclaimed to the whole of humanity and
he told his disciples that never keep it
away from from humankind Proclaim it and
spread it that's what's mentioned in the
prophecy there's nothing like esoteric
or exoteric everything should be told to
the
humankind it's further mentioned in the
Buddhist scriptures in the sacred books
of the East volume number 11 page number
Mah chapter number 5 verse number
36 it says that as Buddha had a servito
by the name of Ananda so shall the M
have a Servo and we know from history
from the SE of M wasallam that the
servor of M wasallam was anas may Allah
be pleased with
him who was the son of Malik pleased
with
him and anas may pleased with him he
says that my
parents gave me to the prophet at the
age of eight and his mother told the
prophet oh messenger of
Allah take this to be your servant and
anas may pleas with him he said that the
prophet referred to him as his son or
the little beloved one and we know an be
pleased with him he always stood by the
prophet in times of peace and in times
of war in times of safety in times of
danger he can very well be compared to
Ananda we know when the Mad elephant
rushes at Buddha Ananda stood by
similarly we know be pleased with him in
the Battle of at the age of 11 even when
the enemies were close to Prophet malli
wasallam anas may Allah be pleased with
him stood by the prophet even in the
Battle of H at the age of 16 when the
enemies who were archers surrounded the
prophet yet pleased with him he stood by
the prophet he can very well be
compared like Ananda when the Mad
elephant rushes at Buddha and Ananda
stays by Buddha so this is the
Fulfillment of the prophecy that the
Mitri will have a Servo it is further
mentioned in the gospel of Buddha page
number 214 that this Mitri to come this
ad Buddha to come will have six
qualities the first is he will get
Enlightenment at night number two he
will become bright when he gets
enlightened number three he will die a
natural death number four he will die at
night number five when he dies he'll
become bright and number six once he
dies he will never be seen in the bodily
form in this Earth again these six
qualities and criteria beit no one but
the last and final messenger Prophet
mmall wasallam we know that Muhammad
sallah Ali wasallam the first wahi he
got was at night time as I mentioned
earlier the Quran says in suran 44 vers
number 2 and 3 and Sur chapter 97 verse
number one that the Quran was revealed
in the night of
power it further says
he will be lit up and We Know M Salli
wasallam had become bright he was
enlightened it further says he will die
a natural death and know mammad wasallam
had a natural death Point number four he
will die at night and we know from the
of be pleased with her that she did not
have oil in the lamp so she borrowed the
oil from the neighbor indicating it was
night when Prophet mam
died it further says that he will become
bright at the time of death and with him
says that Prophet mammad looked bright
when he died and the last point is that
when he dies he will never be seen in
the bodily form on this Earth I know
wasallam when he died in the bodily form
he's buried in Madina and he was never
seen bodly form again all these criteria
mentioned in the Buddhist scriptures
beit no one but the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad sallah Ali
wasallam it's further mentioned in the
Buddhist scriptures in the s books of
the East volume number 10 page number 68
it says that the
tatas they are only
preachers that means the Buddhas to come
they can only preach and Allah says in
the Quran in chapter number 88 verse
number
21 Allah says to the prophet your job is
to deliver the message giving hi is in
the hands of Allah subhana tala it's
further mentioned in sacred books of the
East volume number 10
page number 67 that to go to
paradise even your good deeds are
responsible your good deeds are
responsible for you to go to paradise
and Allah says in Surah alar chapter
number 103 verse number 1
to3 which means by the token of time man
is we in a state of loss except those
who have faith those who have righteous
deed those who exalt people to truth and
those who exalt people to patience and
perance one of the criteria to go to
Jenna is righteous deed which is
mentioned in the Buddhist scriptures and
further it's mentioned
D
151 it gives the criteria of the Buddha
the final M three to come it says that
he will be a mercy to
humankind he will be gentle he be an
example to Human kind he says he'll be
kind and he will be truthful so all
these criteria beit no one but the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam this was in brief
regarding Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam in the Buddhist scriptures
let's discuss the prophecy of muhamad
sallallahu Ali wasallam in the Jewish
and the Christian scriptures the Jewish
and the Christian scriptures we know
that the Bible is divided into the Old
Testament and the New
Testament the Bible
Bible according to the Catholics has 73
books according to the Protestants they
have thrown out seven books as Apocrypha
doubtful from the Old Testament so total
Bible contained 66 books so the New
Testament of the Catholics and the
Protestants contain 27 books but the Old
Testament of the Catholics contains 46
books of the Protestant it contains 39
books the Old Testament speaks about the
stories
about the prophets that came before
Jesus Christ PE be upon him and the New
Testament speaks about the life and the
times of Jesus Christ PE on we'll first
discuss the prophecy of Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam in the Jewish
scriptures it's mentioned in the Old
Testament in the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 18 verse number
18 it says almighty God says I shall
raise them a prophet from among thy
brother
like unto thee and I shall put my words
into his mouth and he shall speak all
that I command him this prophecy says I
shall raise them for Prophet from among
thy Brethren like unto thee like Moses
peace be upon him so the Christian they
say that this prophecy refers to no one
but Prophet Jesus Christ peace be upon
him and when we ask them why does it
refer to Jesus Christ peace be upon him
they tell us because the prophecy says
the prophet to come should be like Moses
peace be upon him and Jesus Christ peace
be upon him was like Moses peace be upon
him and when we ask them how are they
alike they tell us that Moses and Jesus
peace be upon them both of them were
prophets of God and both of them were
Jew that's why this prophecy is talking
about Jesus Christ peace be upon him if
these two are the only criteria if these
two are the only criteria for the
Fulfillment of the prophecy that he
should be a Jew and he should be a
prophet of God then all the prophets
mentioned in the bible after Moses peace
be upon Him fulfill this prophecy for
example Prophet Solomon Ezekiel Isaiah
Daniel hosia Joel John the Baptist peace
be upon them all all of them were
prophets of God and all of them were Jew
all of them fulfill the prophecy if we
analyze we come to know that this
prophecy befits no one better than the
last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad Salli wasallam let's analyze
what does the prophecy say the prophet
phy says I shall raise them a prophet
from among their Brethren like unto thee
like unto Moses peace be upon him if we
analyze Moses and Muhammad peace be upon
them both of them were born naturally
but Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
was not born naturally he was born
without any male intervention and this
is mentioned in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran chapter number 3 verse number
45-47 and is also mentioned in the Bible
in the gospel of Matthew chapter number
one verse number 18 and the Gospel of
Luke chapter number one verse number 35
that he was born without any male
intervention he was born miraculously
therefore Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is like Prophet Moses peace be upon
him and Prophet Jesus is unlike Prophet
Moses peace be upon them further if you
analyze Prophet Muhammad and Prophet
Moses peace be upon them both of them
were married and they had children but
according to the Bible Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he was not married and
he had no children so Jesus is unlike
Moses and Muhammad is like Moses peace
be upon them all further if we
analyze Prophet Moses and Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon them both of them
they died a natural
death but Prophet Jesus Christ peace be
upon him he did not have a natural death
according to the Quran we believe that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him he was
raised up alive Surah chapter number 4
verse number 157 and 158 he did not die
we believe even if you read the
Christian Bible correctly even according
to the Christian Bible we can prove he
did not die he was not crucified but the
Christians think that Jesus Christ peace
be upon him he died on the cross he was
crucified for more details regarding
this topic referred to my video cassette
and the debate was Christ crucified but
even if we agree for sake of argument
what they say is
right we have to agree that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he did not have a
natural death according to Christian
reading of the Bible which is not
correct they believe he died on the
cross it was not a natural death we
believe he was raised up alive both ways
we agree he did not have a natural death
therefore Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
is not like Moses peace be upon him and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
like Moses peace be upon Him further if
you analyze Prophet Moses and Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon them both of them
brought new laws but according to the
Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon him did
not get new law it's mentioned in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 5 verse
number 17 and 18 Jesus Christ peace be
upon Him says think not that I have come
to destroy the law of the prophets I
have come not to destroy but to
fulfill further if we
analyze Muhammad and Moses peace be upon
them besides being prophets of God they
were even worldly kings that means they
could give the punishment of life and
death to the person who deserved it they
could give the punishment of death to
the person who deserved it where Prophet
Jesus peace be upon him he could not do
that and it's mentioned in the Gospel of
John chapter number 18 verse number 36
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him says my
kingdom is not of this
world and further if we analyze Moses
and Muhammad peace be upon
them both of them their people they
accepted them as prophets of God as a
whole but Jesus Christ peace be upon him
his his people as a whole they did not
accept him as a prophet it's mentioned
in the Gospel of John chapter number 1
verse number 11 that they all for him so
here when we analyze we come to know
that Moses and Muhammad peace be upon
them are alike and Moses and Jesus peace
be upon them they are unlike so this
prophecy refers to no one but Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him the prophecy
further says I shall raise them a
prophet from among thy Brethren and we
know that the Arabs are the cousins of
the
Jews Moses was the Jew Muhammad sallah
Ali wasallam was an Arab peace be upon
them both so Arabs and Jews are
cousins furthermore the prophecy says I
shall raise them a prophet from among
thy Brethren like unto thee and I shall
put my words into his mouth and he shall
say all that I command him we know that
Muhammad s Al wasallam used to get the
from Allah subhana wa tala and used to
repeat ver whatever was revealed to him
it was as though words were put to in
his mouth and is to repeat whatever
almighty God is to
say so this prophecy refers to No One
But the last and final messenger Prophet
MMI wasallam the next verse further says
in the book of Deuteronomy chapter
number 18 verse number 19 it says that
if you hearken not unto my
words I
will require of thee or I will take
revenge that means all those who do not
hearken unto the words of this Messenger
to come Prophet malli wasallam almighty
God will take
revenge it's further mentioned in the
book of Isaiah chapter number 29 verse
number 12 it says that the book shall be
given to him who is not learned the book
shall be given to a prophet who's not
learned and when it is said read this I
pray thee he will say I have not learned
and we know that when the first wayi
came to Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam
and AR angel Gabriel
said read our beloved Prophet M
replied which means I have not learned
it this is the verbit Fulfillment of the
prophecy of the book of Isaiah 29 verse
number 12 that when the book is given to
the person who's unlearned we know
Prophet malli wasall was unlettered he
an and when it would be said to him read
he will say I'm not learned and that's
what he
said Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
is also mentioned by name in the Old
Testament it's mentioned in the Song of
Solomon Chapter number 5 verse number 16
it says in
Hebrew Jerusalem which means his mouth
is more sweet he's altogether lovely
he's my beloved he is my friend oh
Daughters of Jerusalem they have
translated Muhammad as altogether lovely
but in in the Semitic languages like
Arabic or Hebrew they add him as a
respect like to ELO God that Elohim for
respect so to the name of Muhammad they
added Muhammad him for respect peace be
upon him so he's mentioned by name in
the original manuscript but now when we
read it's translated to altogether
lovely now let's discuss the prophecy of
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam in the
New Testament as far as the Christians
are concerned whatever is mentioned in
the Old Testament they have to believe
because that is part of the scripture
that's part of the Bible and Allah says
in the Quran in Surah chapter number 7
verse number 157 they follow the
unlettered prophet which is mentioned in
the law and gospel it's further
mentioned Surah saf chapter number 61
verse number six that Jesus Christ peace
be upon Him says to B Israel to the
children of Israel I've been sent as a
messenger to you
confirming what came before me and
giving Glad Tidings of a messenger to
come whose name shall be Ahmed and when
we read the New Testament there are
several Prophecies of prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Al wasallam mentioned in the
New
Testament it's mentioned the Gospel of
John chapter number 14 verse number 16
it says Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
says I shall pray to my father to send
you a comforter who shall abide with you
forever
it's mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 15 verse number 26 and
when the comforter will
come who my father will
send he will glorify me it's mentioned
in the Gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 7 nevertheless I tell you
the truth it is expedient for you that I
go away for if I go not away the
comforter shall not come for if I depart
shall I send
him many of the Christians say that this
comforter refers to the Holy
Spirit now carefully note the prophecy
of Gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 7 says nevertheless I tell
you the truth Jesus Christ peace be upon
him saying nevertheless I tell you the
truth it is experient for you that I go
away for if I go not away the comforter
shall not come for if I depart shall I
send him the criteria for the comforter
to come is that Jesus Christ peace be
upon Him should depart only if he
departs will the comforter come we know
that the Holy Spirit
was there when Jesus Christ peace be
upon him was being baptized the Holy
Spirit was also there before Jesus
Christ peace be upon him was born he was
in the womb of Elizabeth several places
it's mentioned in the bible so surely
this comforter cannot refer to the Holy
Spirit and furthermore the word
comforter if you go to the Greek and
aramic the present scripture it says it
is paraclet and they translate comforter
paraclet means an advocate and if you go
and do research the right word is
pericos which means one who praises a
one who is worth praising irrespective
which is the name of Muhammad sahi
wasallam Ahmed and Muhammad irrespective
whether it is pericos the one who
praises or the praiseworthy or it is
paraclet whether Advocate or comforter
alhamdulillah all these meanings beit no
one better than the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad Sall Ali
wasallam further it's mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 12 to 14 Jesus Christ peace be
upon Him says I have many things to say
unto you but he cannot bear them now for
he when the spirit of truth shall come
he shall guide you onto all truth he
shall not speak of himself all that he
hear shall he speak he shall glorify me
he shall show you things to come this
prophecy says I have have many things to
say unto you but he cannot bear them now
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him tells the
people I have many things to say unto
you but he cannot bear them now for he
when the spirit of truth shall come he
shall guide you onto all truth he shall
not speak of himself all that ear shall
he speak you know mhammad sallu Ali
wasallam whatever was revealed to him he
spoke verbit
him he shall not speak of himself all
that he year shall he speak he shall
show you things to come he shall glorify
me and we know Muhammad sallallah
wasallam
has glorified Jesus Christ peace be upon
him in the Quran and in several Hadith
we consider Jesus Christ peace be upon
him to be one of the mightiest
messengers of Allah subhana wa tala we
believe that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was the Messiah translated Christ we
believe that he was born miraculously
without any male Intervention which many
modern Christians today did not believe
we believe that he gave life to the Dead
with God's permission we believe he
healed those born blind lepers with
God's permission so Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam did glorify
Jesus Christ peace be upon him so this
prophecy refers to No One But the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alhi wasallam this was in
brief regarding the mention of Muhammad
sallallahu alhi wasallam in the
Christian scriptures time doesn't permit
me
to go and give more quotations but this
is just a nutshell the tip of an iceberg
regarding the mention of M wasallam in
the various World religious scriptures I
would like to end my talk with the
quotation of the Glorious Quran where
Allah says in chapter number 108 Allah
says which means we have granted him the
Fountain of
abundance and pray to thy Lord and
sacrifice the name of thy Lord and
anyone who hated thee hated Muhammad
wasallam he will be cut off from all
Future
Hope J Allah Dr Zakir for your very very
informative lecture
today now we come to the second part of
our program and that is question answer
session the question answer session
would be conducted as
follows the mics are there at my left
and in my front in the center a and
there is a mic in the ladies section as
well those who want to ask questions may
come to these mics and they can ask
questions first of all questions that
would be asked would be related to the
topic except to the non-muslim Muslim
brothers who will have the right to ask
any question that they would like to ask
the questioner has to give his name and
profession the question should be very
short and brief without going into any
introductory speech that would save time
I would especially request our
volunteers to ensure that the person who
comes to the mic is a non-muslim now we
begin our question answer session with a
mic on my left left hand any brother
especially non-muslim brother who would
like to ask a question may feel free to
come and ask a
question respected n sa my name is V
balas subam I would like to ask a
question what is the definition of sin
in Islam what are the various kinds of
sins how is this definition different
from that given in Hinduism Christianity
and other religions thank you the
brother asked the question that what is
the definition of sin in Islam and how
does it differ from the definition in
Hinduism and Christianity in short sin
means disobeying the Commandment of
almighty God if whatever almighty God
says and if you go against it it's a sin
for example almighty God says that you
should pray if you don't pray you're are
doing a sin if Almighty God says don't
have alcohol and if you have alcohol
you're doing a sin so disobeying the
Commandment of almighty God in short is
a sin and this sin has a similar
definition in all the religions
including Hinduism and Christianity hope
the answer the
question question from the center mic
please Dr sakir N I am Jeri Thomas I am
a research scholar in journalism at the
usmania University and I have I we and
our friends run a site called saki
times.com I have questions to you one I
always knew that Quran is incomplete
without Hadith now you are referring to
other scriptures also since you have
referred to Bible Bible says anybody who
denies Jesus Christ is the spirit of
antichrist that is a prophecy and I also
know that Hadi says that Muhammad had
diabolical inspiration what should I
conclude from this the brother asked a
question in which I mentioned a few
sentences he said that he knows that the
Quran is incomplete without the Hadith
and now he has heard other scriptures
also that means if I quote the Bible
that means you have to follow the Bible
and he say the Bible says anyone who
does not believe and deny Jesus Christ
peace be upon him will go to hell etc
etc so what are my comments Point number
one the Quran is not incomplete without
the Hadith the Quran is complete
itself but to understand the Quran you
have to go to the commentary of the
Quran the commentary of the Quran is the
Hadith that is the authentic saying of
prophet Muhammad
wasallam the Quran by itself is a
complete book alhamdulillah by itself
but if you want commentary in more
details about it then you
refer to the sayings authentic sayings
of Muhammad sahi wasallam which we call
as now just because I quoted the other
scriptures that does not mean I agree
that all the other scriptures are the
word of God please don't misunderstand
me I was using the strategy of the Quran
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran chapter 3 verse number
64 come to Common terms between us and
you
we coming to Common terms Allah says in
the Quran inah number 13 verse number
38 and in every age have we sent a
revelation Allah sent several Revelation
several books by name only four are
mentioned in the Quran the tah the Zab
the injil and the Quran the Torah is the
the Revelation which was given to Moses
peace be upon him the zabur is theah the
Revelation which was given to David
peace be upon him the angil is the way
the Revelation which was given to to
Jesus Christ peace be upon him and Quran
is the last and final Revelation which
was given to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him now since all the previous
Revelations came only for a particular
group of people and they were meant to
be followed in totality for a particular
time period almighty God did not think
it fit to preserve it in pristine Purity
but because Quran was the last 10 final
Revelation Allah says in the Quran in
Surah hijar chapter number 15 verse
number n we have revealed the Quran and
we shall guard it from
corruption so Quran is the only
religious book on the face of the Earth
which is in its pure form I'm not saying
that even the scholars of comparative
religion including William Moore who's
one of the stonest critics of Islam
being a Christian he said 200 years
earlier that there is no religious book
there is no religious book which has
maintained its pure for form for more
than 1200 years now it is more than
14400 years like the Quran being a
Christian being a stous Critic of
Islam he has to be truthful that Quran
in its pure form now all the other
religious scriptures have changed its
form including the Bible I don't
consider the Bible to be the word of God
we Muslims believe in the wah which was
given to Jesus Christ peace be upon him
the
inil but the present Bible that we have
brother this Bible it's a mixture it may
contain words of God which match with
the Quran I've got no problem in
accepting into the word of God it also
contains the words of the prophets it
contains the word of historians I'm
sorry to say it even contains
pornography I can't quote it here I
can't it even contains hundreds of
contradictions scientific errors
mathematical errors which I can't repeat
here but I had a
dialogue with Dr William Campbell he
wrote a book against Islam the Quran and
the Bible in the light of History and
Science and he said the Quran has got 30
scientific errors I went to USA he's
from Philadelphia and we had a debate in
the year 2000 1 April on the topic the
Quran and the Bible in light of Science
and I answered to all his allegations
and when I pointed out 38 contradictions
in the Bible he could not reply to
them Allah says in the Quan inak number
2 verse number 79 Allah
says vote to those who write the book
with their own hands and then say this
is from Allah to traffic with it for a
miserable price vote to those of what
they write vote to those of what they
earn so today's Bible if you know the
word bible is not there in the Bible it
comes from the Greek word biblos
meaning a book of books and the scholars
say there are many authors of the Bible
not I the Christian scholar so the
present Bible I don't consider it to be
the word of God similarly if you ask me
can you consider V to be the word of God
can you consider the Buddhist scripture
to be the word of God can you consider
the Paris word of God what I
say maybe they were maybe they were not
since there were many scriptures sent by
Allah subhana tala many books by name
fora mention but there were many other
like Su several others so what I say
maybe Hindu scriptures maybe word of God
maybe Buddhist scriptures maybe word of
God maybe Pari scriptures were the word
of God but even if they were they were
meant for those people and for that time
today you have to follow the last and
final Revelation that is the Glorious
Quran so any human being whether you're
living in India in America in Canada in
UK in Singapore in South Arabia all the
human beings in the world should follow
the last and final Revelation the
Glorious Quran and the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him I'm not saying Hindu scripture is
the word of God even if it was it was
meant for those people and for that time
the Hindu Scholars agree that the
scriptures have been changed the
Buddhist Scholars agree that Buddhist
scriptures have been changed all just
call of their own religion except Islam
they agree that the scriptures have gone
changes down the line down the ages but
even if I agree for sake of argument it
is the word of God even if it's since
the followers of that religion they
believe it to be the word of God they
should follow every letter every word of
the scripture so if the Buddhist believe
their scripture word of God the Hindus
believe their scripture to be the word
of God the Christians believe their
scripture word of God so all your
scriptures are saying you have to follow
the teachings of the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him so since you consider to be the word
of God God I say maybe it is maybe it is
not since you believe it to be the word
of God you have to follow your
scriptures so you have to believe in the
last 10 final
Messenger as I mentioned in the Bible in
the Gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 12 to 14 Jesus Christ peace
be upon Him says I have many things to
say unto you but he cannot bear them now
for he when the spirit of truth shall
come he shall guide you unto all tro he
shall not speak of himself all that he
he shall he speak he shall show you
things to come he shall glorify me who
is this
person Muhammad sah wasallam was there
any religious person who has glorified
Jesus Christ peace be upon him besides
mhammad s wasallam you rightly said that
anyone who denies Jesus Christ peace be
upon him will go to hell you said I
agree with that statement I agree no
muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him and we have to say peace be upon him
you may say Jesus I cannot say I have to
say peace be upon him if I as a
religious person
if I do not add peace be upon him I'll
be kicked out a lay man can do that I
have to add peace be upon him so no
muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him we believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of Allah subhana wa
taala we
believe that he was born miraculously
without any male Intervention which many
modern decoran not believe we believe
that he gave life to the Dead with God's
permission we believe that he healed
those born BL and lepers is God's
permission the Muslim and the Christians
are going together but I know what you
mean when you mean believe in Jesus
Christ you mean what do you mean believe
is God correct can you on the
microphone when you say believe in Jesus
Christ means what believe is the prophet
I believe this statement that I am the
way the truth and the life what does it
mean it means that he is the Incarnate
god brother as has follow this question
John chapter the same I will give you
the reference I'll give you the
reference also no
problem what the reference John chapter
14 you can refer verse number I have the
Bible I can tell you John 14: 16 so not
16 verse number six it's not 16 sorry Mr
n you don't have to teach me Bible you
just tell whatever your
misrepresentations will be answered in
our site that's right brother you you
are not quoting you have the Bible in
your bag correct you take out the Bible
from your bag and you're quoting Gospel
of John chapter number 14 verse number
six it's not
16 and you said that Jesus Christ peace
be upon him he said that he was
God I'll come to your question before I
come to your question let me tell you
one thing I've read the Bible there is
not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon himself says that I am God
or where he says worship me if any
Christian can point out to me a single
unequivocal statement a single
unambiguous statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
him himself says that I am God or where
he says worship me I ready to accept
Christianity
[Applause]
Today I not speaking on behalf of my
other Muslim Brothers I'm putting my
head on the guillotine I'm a St of
compared religion you have read the
Bible even I have studied the Bible you
said that I should not teach you the
Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
says seek ye the truth and the truth
shall free you I will insh show you the
truth and the truth shall free you today
inshallah as I mentioned earlier there
is not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him himself says that I am
God or he says worship me in fact if you
read the Bible Jesus Christ peace be
upon himself sa it's mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 14 verse
number 28 he said my father is greater
than I Gospel of John chapter number 10
verse number 29 my father is greater
than All gospel of Matthew chapter
number 12 verse number 28 I cast out
Devils with the spirit of God Gospel of
Luke chapter number 11 verse number 20 I
with the Finger of God cast out Devils
Gospel of John chapter number five verse
number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of my father anyone who
says I seek not my will the will of
almighty God is's a Muslim Jesus Christ
peace be upon the Muslim he never
claimed Divinity it's clearly mentioned
in the book of Acts chapter number two
verse number 22 it says that e men of
Israel listen to this Jesus of Nazareth
a man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and miracles and signs which God
did by him and you are witnessed to it a
man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and miracles and signs which God
did by him and you are witness to it so
the Bible clearly said that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was a man he was one
of the mightiest messengers of God but
not God there is not a single
unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or he says
worship me you quoted a verse to prove
your point from Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 6 which says
where Jesus Christ peace be upon himself
says that I am the way the truth and the
life no man cometh to my father but
through me now this is again quoting out
of context people pick up verses from
the Quran and quote out of context to
malign similarly Christian missionaries
quote the Bible out of context I want to
tell you a truth to you you can open the
Bible if you doubt me open the Bible for
the context go to verse number one
Gospel of John chapter number 14 verse
number one says that why are you afraid
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him says if
you have faith in God have faith in me
in my father's Mansion there are many
houses and I'm going there to prepare a
place for you and when I go I will tell
you so ask where thou art good he said
don't you know where I go he said no
then he says that show us the way where
thou goest so then Jesus Christ peace be
replies I am the way the truth and the
life when ask Jesus Christ peace be show
us the way to God then Jesus Christ
peace be replies I am the way the truth
and the life no man cometh unto thy
father but through me we agree at the
time of the messenger every messenger
was the way the truth and the life no
man came unto God but through the way of
that messenger at the time of Jesus I
agree with the Bible that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he was the way the
truth and the life no man came unto
almighty God but through the teachings
of Jesus Christ peace be upon him at the
time of Moses Moses was the way the
truth and the life no man came unto
almighty God but through the teachings
of Moses peace be upon him but today
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said I
have many things to say unto you further
he says in the Gospel of John chapter
number 16 verse number 12- 14 I have
many things to say unto you but you
cannot bear them now for he when the
spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you onto all Tru he shall not
speak of himself all that he hear shall
he speak he shall show you things to
come he shall glorify me at today's time
at today's time the messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him is the way
the truth and the life no man cometh to
almighty God but through the teachings
of prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
since Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
as the last and final messenger in
today's age irrespective whether a
person is living in USA in Canada in UK
in India in Saudi Arabia any part of the
world for every human being today
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
the way the truth and the life no man
cometh unto almighty God but through the
teaching of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and this is what all the major
scriptures say including the Bible so
hope now you have been enlightened to
the truth and hope inshallah you will
come to the truth and truth shall free
you now the question will come from the
sister section if any non-muslim sister
is there please come to the mic and ask
her the
question for